[Music]
hey y'all we're back again look tom's
got a jacket on yeah it's cold in here
it is kind of cold in here i think i
think it only got up to 52 degrees today
that was the high so in florida that's
pretty cold i know some of you are just
like man shut up it's like 52. it's 64
in here man this [ __ ] house that's
[ __ ] freezing for us i like it yeah
i'm quite comfortable cats love it
cookie brought it around like she smells
like a whole [ __ ] herd of buffalos
i know i woke up at like four or five in
the morning and it's like she's like
yeah she loves it seriously for a little
bitty 10 pound cat maybe 10 pounds she
sounds like a whole bunch of like big
fat people running around i don't think
she's ten pounds
she might not be well no she went we
took her to the vet i think she was nine
pounds but that was a while back i think
she's a little bit chubbier since then
you're fat she's not fat shut up don't
tell her that okay all right you're
gonna give her a complex you're gonna
get a complex okay she's like i'm not
fat [ __ ] she doesn't know what i'm
saying yes she does
she probably doesn't care she's like
screw you daddy she's like that's good
she's like yeah that's right check out
my pouch
i think she does know what we're saying
a lot of times though yeah she goes i'll
say something and then she'll
she'll she'll do things yeah okay she
reacts the way that you would if she
knew she understood about half of what
you're saying yeah she gets it
uh yeah so just like i promised
yesterday we're talking about the the
blob the 80s remake
and i have to say
because god damn the 80s were a really
good time for
awesome remakes of 50s movies yeah right
they had the thing and the fly and like
there was some other ones where
everybody was just kind of like oh we
like that cheesy ass idea like from the
50s sci-fi movie but let's like gore it
up and like make it way way better well
the directors and the producers grew up
in the 50s so now they're in charge they
could remake that movie
see and what if you're gonna do a remake
i would rather you did that like take
something that was a great idea but it
wasn't executed all that well either
because like it was the wrong person
doing it or they didn't have the budget
or whatever they or they didn't miss
they missed the twist
yeah or something um but if
the original thing is not like the book
yeah the uh carpenter's thing is closer
to closer to
the book which is uh was it who goes
there which is yeah you know which is
that's where the thing came from yeah
but uh but yeah so this one i mean
obviously now the 1958 blob is fun i
will say that yeah um
but mcqueen yeah with steve mcqueen in
it playing a 40 year old high school
student yeah
which the 30 year old that's fine they
have they did that a lot back then so
i'll give it a pass like i said have you
ever seen some of those cheesy 50s
monster movies like teenagers from outer
space and they're all like 35 they're
all like 35 years old maybe they're not
that old but they all look that old ones
they do i'm just like even i saw it on
mst and they're just like really old
teenagers from outer space holy [ __ ] uh
but yeah so some of those movies we saw
though i recognized where they were
filmed on california when i was a kid
back when that [ __ ] was still just like
an open field
and they'd have they were 60s mostly 60s
and they'd have some 60s girls in there
and they still in the early 60s they're
still kind of dressed like the 50s it's
kind of funny because
you could tell that they're [ __ ]
20
but they're kind of dressed like old
women and they kind of act a little bit
like old women
yeah but
then they try to be [ __ ] sexy and
[ __ ] but it's funny to see like a
[ __ ] it just and then they look old or
they're they're even old vibes but
they're not old yeah and they're acting
more mature than they should yeah it's
more a vibe thing than a looks thing
it's hard to put your finger on yeah
weird times
but so um i was i was listening to
something about this earlier uh where
they were talking about uh you know when
they were talking about redoing the blob
because they said look like the the idea
for the blob because honestly prior to
that like in the early 1950s and you had
all of these kind of sci-fi big bug uh
monster movies and that kind of stuff
and they're like honestly even though
the blob the 1958 version was like
really cheesy
they're like behind that was a great
idea because this is
an alien form which hadn't really been
seen in the movies before it was just a
blob like a sludge you couldn't reason
with it it wasn't like a monster it
didn't care about you it was just kind
of like came to the earth and it was
almost kind of like a natural disaster
where it was just kind of like eating
people it was an accurate portrayal of a
right alien creature it was a it was an
amoeba basically yes space amoeba right
so what they were saying when they were
talking about doing the developing the
80s version was like that's a great
[ __ ] idea for a monster so let's make
it
you know kind of like what we liked
about the 50s one but make it like much
scarier much gorier i mean because
obviously the 50s version wasn't all
that gory now i had forgotten too the
guy that directed this uh chuck russell
and uh i had forgotten too that he that
the screenwriter on this was
frank [ __ ] darabont i forgot
that he was a screenwriter on this so
him and chuck russell met when they were
doing hell night in 1981 that was the
linda blair uh slasher movie
and uh i think they did i think they
wrote uh
neighborhood elm street three three
warriors which was like the other really
good one
and i mean frank darabont obviously i
mean he went on to do most famous usual
for doing like all the stephen king
adaptation to the mist uh obviously he's
the [ __ ] shawshank redemption did he
get an oscar for that i kind of feel
like he got nominated so he obviously
knows how to write a [ __ ]
movie um and watching this movie again
because i saw this back in i might have
seen it in the theater
uh i think because i saw a lot of movies
in 1988 i never was in the theater on
vhs but i remember this being all over
fangoria and i have to say watching it
again last night the special effects in
this still look really good i'm glad to
have seen it and glad to have seen it
the way it was intended to be seen
because it didn't look that good on vhs
it was a good movie yeah but i didn't
realize that the special effects were
as good as they were i mean it's
it's a high budget movie you know i
would i'd probably put it there
technically up there with gremlins maybe
maybe a little bit more it was around
that same time wasn't it maybe a little
bit no gremlins was uh 84. which was
four years before
four years after
so this came out four years after yeah
four years after so uh but yeah
it and it's almost spielbergian in its
[ __ ] scope it's it's a good movie
real good yeah it's still based around a
small town
uh they it's weird because they shot
this in louisiana
even though it's supposed to be the
wikipedia page says it's supposed to be
california i thought it was supposed to
be colorado
i could be wrong about that
it's like it's like a small ski town
yeah uh but i thought it was colorado i
could be wrong maybe it was supposed to
be california but they shot it in in
louisiana anyway but they actually the
the town that they found
there was a scene i don't know if they
did this on purpose like when they were
scouting locations but there was a scene
like the beginning of the scene where
they showed the this small town and it
looks like it's all abandoned like
nobody lives there and then they scroll
across and then you see oh the reason
that it's abandoned is everybody's at
the football game
yeah um
they said that
and it's this great like iconic opening
shot where they're scrolling across from
like a cemetery to like a football
stadium
and that was in the script written like
that but they actually found a town
where
that was the case like they didn't
change anything you know what i mean so
i thought that was like really funny but
that's like a great scene like
establishing you know this kind of small
town and you know it's just kind of this
sense of foreboding
uh so you get your characters
uh meg kind of like the main character i
guess uh and
flag brian flagg and another thing i
thought too was because this was frank
darabont i thought that he named that
character flag because of randall flag
you know from the stand uh apparently he
didn't it was just like a total accident
but there are other homages to the stand
in this though so i i don't know i find
that hard to believe but okay um he says
he didn't so there you go uh kevin
dillon and his amazing mullet yeah uh
are
are in this and i didn't say something
though for you to what's that um he
actually rides around a little uh
there's some kind of split single looks
like a royal enfield or a
or maybe like a triumph tiger or
something sorry i think it was a triumph
type tiger okay um duke ride he's got he
[ __ ]
lights up the rear tire and does a
[ __ ] 180
on his [ __ ] leg and [ __ ] he was
it's a small bike it's easy to manhandle
that bike but i was uh i was impressed
he's he was competent on that motorcycle
that was him that did that that stunt
i was looking yeah you know i'm talking
about where he's doing 180 yeah off his
[ __ ] leg from a standstill
you got to get the hang of that
and uh you know he did it yeah it's
pretty good
but we were talking a little bit dude
yeah which you know they didn't so a lot
of guys would be would put us out and
have a [ __ ] stunt double do that but
he did it
well sometimes sometimes they want to do
it but the production company especially
on bigger budget movies like you were
absolutely not doing that because we
can't insure you right yeah you know
what i mean
um but there's that too that that's a
trick that is not a moving trick you
could do it in place
so that maybe that's why they let him do
it yeah you know it's not like it's not
like
catching air off a [ __ ] ramp you know
what i mean which he does later on but
that's got to be a stop double that did
that yeah because that's kind of how
they build up his character he's like
jumping the bridge at the beginning and
then like he falls off yeah and that's
when he kind of like first sees the the
bum who ends up being the first uh you
know victim of the blob he dumps that
[ __ ]
tiger nowadays you'd never dump that
bike that bike's [ __ ] worth a minute
now
challenge you to find a [ __ ] tiger
trap tiger they're worth a lot of money
but he dumps it right in the [ __ ]
dirt
well back then back then they weren't
worth as much yeah
but i was going to say though we were
talking about his uh magnificent mullet
in the movie
uh i'm not sure i i heard i don't know
if this is true or not but both him and
shawnee smith who plays meg they both
are wearing hair extensions in this so
that's not entirely all their own hair
because she kind of has like a
it's really kind of big and sprayed in
the front and then it's like long in the
back and i totally remember girls having
that haircut in like 87 or 88
but bring themselves to actually grow
that haircut
all right even though that was very
stylish for for the 1980s like i said i
don't think anybody really batted it if
you were like a winger fan and you liked
[ __ ] john bon jovi and [ __ ] you
were getting [ __ ] you know
getting slammed in the back of the
[ __ ] grand national yeah that was the
hair that cut you had
grant there's a [ __ ] tell you all
about it [ __ ] we went to school with
those girls
you had to have a iraq z with a big old
bird on the hood
yeah i remember a couple days
yeah uh danny rolling ghostface says the
dude that got melted by toxic waste in
robocop plays a prick really good in
this film yeah he's in it not a huge
part but yeah he's in it what was that
character's name in robocop was his name
wesley i think his name was wesley
wasn't it yeah we i don't know we were
trying to remember i remember that but
he there's a cool scene where he [ __ ]
pulls up the gas station on it i think
it was a [ __ ] ninja's gpc and he
jumps out with a [ __ ] mac 10 and
starts threatening the dab cash version
she tried to shoot through the bullet
put his bulletproof glass he had that
yellow cigarette
throws it in the gasoline [ __ ] it was
like that was like some [ __ ] you could
actually do in detroit as grandparents
that was detroit that's the way it was
i was living down there this is robocop
we're talking robocop not the blob
[Laughter]
uh he also says also the best kill in
this
that's a lot of competition in that area
have to say uh has to be the loud
talking moviegoer who gets gripped up
into the ceiling and dies just saying i
know i kind of like cheered at that i
have to admit because i [ __ ] hate it
when people talk in movies and i'm like
god damn i wish the [ __ ] blob would
come and like pull those people up into
the ceiling honestly i have to say
god there's so many good kills in this
uh you know the the trash compactor or
the garbage disposal kill [ __ ] great
that still looks fantastic i think
um because i don't i don't like the
garbage disposal either
excellent practical effects in this
movie yeah um the uh paul getting killed
like where he just gets kind of sucked
up like that with his arms out like that
and then she pulls one of his ones of
his arms off like it squishes off uh
candy clark's character the waitress
which was kind of sad because she was
like a good character she gets killed in
the [ __ ]
uh phone booth yeah after she sees like
the the cop
like floating on the outside who's
supposed to have a date with her that's
one thing about frank darabont he is
absolutely i mean if you've seen the
mist you know he is absolutely not
afraid to kill off every [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] movie well he wanted to do
what he did with this he was kind of
trying to set up like the sort of like
football jock characters as kind of like
the heroes
toward the beginning and then spoiler
alert they get killed like pretty
quickly yeah and it ends up actually
being meg the sort of cheerleader girl
uh she lives and then it's sort of like
the juvenile delinquent character he's
actually a good guy yeah they just like
fun yeah they just like you know he's
just like perceived as being a bad guy
because he doesn't trust authority um
even though in this movie he absolutely
was right not to he's kind of a pro golf
character in a way kind of yeah god
[ __ ] but it's more like 50s like a
50s greaser yeah but which like i said
that was a big thing in the 80s there
was like a lot of
nostalgia 50s nostalgia
uh in reality it would have been the
punk rock kid or the [ __ ] kid that
would have been
and i like that i like that they made
him kind of prickly at the beginning but
but he was still a good guy at heart he
was just a little bit of a troublemaker
and the cops didn't like him and [ __ ]
like that but his mistrust of authority
actually ended up he actually ended up
saving people because he figured out
what was going on
uh amanda garrett says i thought that
rob zombie was gonna remake this movie i
heard that too and i'm thank god that
[ __ ] didn't happen rude
i mean
look look i love you rob zombie i do but
he's got to stay at what he's good at
what he's good at is rejects type stay
in your lane yeah i just i can't see
yeah he's good at that kind of stuff
right like real yucky like rednecky
horror like he's good at that like texas
chainsaw massacre type [ __ ] yeah don't
try to be really good at hills have eyes
you'd probably really be good at that
yeah he's good at that kind of stuff
yeah i really don't see him being able
to do a sort of alien sci-fi
i don't know even though this movie like
i said it ended up being like super dark
i really like the way even a lot of
really likable characters like i said
the the waitress played by candy clark
they kind of set up like a little bit of
a romance developing between her and the
sheriff and she's really nice and sweet
and helpful and everything and then bam
she ends up getting killed too like
pretty much everybody ends up getting
killed also a little kid ends up getting
killed and it's funny because i i heard
that the producers were like you
absolutely can't kill any children on
this film and they were just like [ __ ]
you we're doing it anyway so they didn't
kill meg's little brother but they
killed meg's little brother's friend
this is a good time for me to talk about
what they just thought what you just
talked about all right the reason why
you wouldn't want rod zombie to redo
this film is because 50s sci-fi horror
has a kind of a good-natured element to
it
it's not even if it's dark
even if it's got kids that's getting
killed in it there's something kind of
positive about it there's something yeah
there's something kind of you know
not positive positive what's another
word i'm talking about
optimistic yeah
it's very it has an optimistic side to
it which kind of uh
alleviates the [ __ ] trauma that you
see happening in the movie you know that
it's all going to work out fine you know
what i mean that's
that's the way the 50s sci-fi [ __ ] did
and rob zombie doesn't have that all
right um if
that's not his style
his style is [ __ ] uh doom and gloom
[ __ ] grotesque
he needs this if he's gonna redo one
another movie besides devil rejects i'm
gonna say hills have eyes he'd probably
kick ass on that
he should do a remake of gator bait
yeah he could probably do that
or like some
he's more like or herschel gordon lewis
or something like that he seems like
that seems like more his style that's
more his speech oh that's the one with
the uh the town that comes back to get
rid of yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah redneck
town yeah yeah just he'd like he could
do like blood feast or something like
that or to or 2008 i'd really like to
see hills have eyes or the car they
already remade the hills have eyes rob
zombie didn't remake it no i don't like
to rob zombies hills
i wouldn't mind seeing robs out seeing
rob zombies uh the car
yeah i probably do really good with that
yeah that could be super gory yeah which
is kind of like a proto christine in a
way car comes out of the [ __ ] crown
from hell and chases dudes down out in
the desert he'd probably do real good
with that rob zombie probably kick ass
with that i'd like to see rob zombie
redo omega man
i don't know that's cool that's treading
into some gray area [ __ ] badass song
about it
well that doesn't mean that he can make
a badass movie eventually yeah those are
two completely different things i'd like
to see his script
you know he can't do it he can't do a
damn
halloween
edition to it remember what he did to
halloween
yeah
some people like that i didn't like it i
didn't like it no i didn't i didn't like
it
i didn't need to see michael myers as a
kid and he got abused and all that it's
like it's too it demystified the
character and makes them less scared
again i don't like it and i've talked
about that before uh jake adams says the
1988 blob didn't [ __ ] around it
absolutely did not honestly
yeah and i think that's what i liked so
much about this it has
um the fun
and
the personality and the sort of like you
said optimism a little bit although it
is a lot more cynical than the 50s one
because one change that they did make
the 1958 blob uh you know the blob was
just a straight up alien it just like
fell to the earth in a meteor
now it does in this one too
but during the course of the movie you
find out that it's actually not an alien
but it's actually like a bio weapon
that was developed on earth and they've
been like keeping it in a satellite and
it just like crashed so it's actually
man-made
um at that angle yeah so
this is so this is actually like a more
cynical take on it in the sense that
it's not just like an alien being that
comes there like randomly i liked it
better in the original that it was an
alien being that came in a damn meteor
yeah in a rock i mean i get likely that
kind of yeah i get why they changed it i
mean the 80s was a lot more cynical time
than the 50s yeah and i think they
wanted
to you know to kind of get across that a
little bit of that like anti-authority
or like a little bit conspiracy theory
type
vibe to it because that was kind of
popular you know it was like you know
they live and all that kind of stuff so
um sounds crazy you wouldn't think it'd
be possible or plausible that an alien
amoeba could land on the earth in a
meteor it happens all the time yeah
there's been they they believe but
material is exchanged between
mars and earth over the billions of
years it has exchanged many times
through asteroid impacts
things hit mars and boom blasted off
into into space reaches escape velocity
and lands here on earth it it's
plausible that biological material is
transferred that way
it could be that life came from mars and
was brought here
like cross-contamination yeah so yeah
if you had a big enough rock
and you had an amoeba in there it might
survive for billions of years in [ __ ]
suspended animation
you know if it's a real primitive
organism it could land on the earth
most of it would burn up but it wouldn't
get what doesn't get very hot in the
middle and then that [ __ ] could
rock and it could come out and get you
it's plausible
it's impossible unlikely or it would
have happened already
because you know there it's pretty old
but it could be that life
life spraying
started it somewhere else in the [ __ ]
earth's life was basically contamination
it was brought here that's another
possibility
you know when it was microbes just
microbes
yeah i think it's a [ __ ] excellent
idea
yeah and like i said really ahead of its
time like a monster that hadn't been
done before so so i think that it was i
mean with such a good idea as that i
think it was good that they chose in the
80s to like reboot it because that is
and i i was listening to um you know
something that kind of did a deep dive
on this and they were talking about like
all the producers and writers behind it
and they were just like we just loved
the idea of this monster that didn't
it was it wasn't even like evil it just
didn't give a [ __ ] about you
it was just like yeah it was just like a
microbe that we just wanted to eat so it
could get bigger it wasn't nothing
personal in the 50s that's a [ __ ]
futuristic idea yeah because in the 50s
in alien
alien space movies and [ __ ] my alien
monster movies were dudes in stupid
suits that came down to flying saucer or
or a forced perspective big bugs yeah
big bugs well that's not alien yeah
that's true but alien [ __ ] was always
just some man in a [ __ ] space suit
who could be reasoned with usually hit
you with a to some degree he wanted to
conquer your planet he hit a ray gun big
[ __ ] deal
all right
what's [ __ ] far more plausible like
the blob or the thing much scarier
scarier yeah
because there's we there was nothing you
could do about that and honestly that
kind of like shows you know the 50s when
they did that a little bit but they
couldn't go too far because they wanted
to like keep it a little bit
light-hearted i guess this one went a
lot darker with it in the sense that
all like pretty much everybody well not
everybody but most of the characters get
killed like even the even the ones that
you think are going to be main
characters
and a lot of the town gets destroyed
like before they figure out
you know how to
uh destroy the the monster another one
that was kind of plausible was slither
yeah that's true that was kind of like a
combination of the thing and the blob
but that's not an old idea that was
that's pretty modern movie that was two
thousands i think that's luther
yeah 2006. that's good i want to say
yeah yeah i really like slytherin yeah
um
jake adams says yeah this one had the
big swerve of who the main character was
going to be gave that feeling if anyone
can get eaten yeah and that's absolutely
what they wanted to get across i think
they were trying to do like a psycho
type of thing where you know you have
this big star in it and then halfway
through the movie she gets [ __ ]
killed and so they were trying to set up
particularly paul i think the the
character of paul the um you know the
football guy that was taking meg out on
the date
they wanted to set up you know they had
the whole scene in the in the pharmacy
where he's trying to buy condoms and all
this other kind of stuff and then they
had like his rapey friend that was out
there
molesting
a girl that had passed out that was
[ __ ] funny i had forgotten about that
he was out there with that chick right
in the car and
they were drinking in the car
and i don't i didn't know like whether
he gave her something like roofied her
because she fell asleep right
and then he started
he's like oh you know yeah
are you awfully hot and he starts he's
gonna like totally gonna feel upper
titty but the funniest thing about that
scene i mean the scene's not funny
nowadays because now it's kind of
horrifying but like you he opened up the
trunk and he had a whole [ __ ] bar in
there yeah he had a whole bar and he had
a whole bunch of like uh class rings
like on chains so he could just like so
he was running all these girls at the
same time i'm like oh they were
neighborhoods about that type of dude
nowadays
it's like super funny but he gets eaten
too but uh it was funny though it was
just supposed to be it was funny it was
just it was it was just an extreme
stereotype of the dude in high school
that you knew that was like that yeah
like the football player jock type of
dude that was just like running through
all the kinda well he was in the movie
he wasn't he was like he was he was a
football player yeah he was he was yeah
he was like a joke oh he was a jack yeah
he was he was the one that was trying to
run all that [ __ ] girls thought he
was [ __ ] casanova yeah yeah but uh
yeah they they definitely do try to set
up
the character paul not not the rapey guy
but his friend they do try to set him up
as like him being you know they're the
ones that find the hobo
that has the thing on his arm and they
them and uh flag you know the the punk
guy with the mullet they bring him to
the hospital
and then that's a great effect too like
when they go in there and uh you know
shawnee smith like sees the bomb like
laying in the hospital room and there's
like something moving under the blanket
she's like what the [ __ ] is that and
these guys over there and booze and then
like the whole dude's been like [ __ ]
dissolved and it's just like it looks so
[ __ ] good
and then like basically the blob like
gets out and eats paul like i said and
it looks good they used um
i guess it's like methyl cellulose which
is that [ __ ] that they put in um
milkshakes like to thicken them it's
like this real slippery [ __ ] yeah uh
they used that
and apparently for that scene where that
football player paul gets killed
um they basically just like stretched it
for real like over his face so that is
him in there he said it felt like being
waterboarded yeah so they pulled yeah
they say pulled it over his face and it
looks [ __ ] great yeah instead of his
arms are out like that and like i said
she's trying to like help him and like
just pulls his arm out the thing and
yeah [ __ ] like that and that's all of
you i mean eat you alive i mean can you
imagine like what the and like i said
that's the special effects in this still
so good and i love like the scene in the
diner where the one guy george gets
pulled into
you know something bad's going to happen
it's like the garbage disposal gets all
backed up
and the waitress like candy clark she's
all kind of like oh man [ __ ] what the
hell and then she says to like the other
guy working there george she's like hey
can you like take a look at that or
whatever and he's like trying to plunge
it and he's just like man what the [ __ ]
and then you know he's going to stick
his hand in there
you're watching the movie being like
please don't stick your hand in there
but he does and he sticks his hand in
there and this he just gets
pulled into the garbage like head first
it looks so good i had forgotten how
good
that effect looked
and i
because i was watching it last night i'm
like god damn yeah i couldn't even
figure out how they did it
yeah
they actually had the actor the stuntman
like do a handstand in the sink
and then i think they had like some kind
of weird mannequin or something that
would that would crush like down to the
size
so they did it i mean obviously they did
it practically 1988 they did have some
access to cgi and i think there were
some minor
cgi like i think um
when the blob freezes because that's
it's uh that's its weakness is cold i
think that was in the original yeah too
right yeah um
so when it freezes to like crystals
they use cgi to like put like little
glittery
like purple to make it like look cooler
but i think that's the only cgi they
used in this freezing is how they
explained it got here across the [ __ ]
vastness of space yes it was inside a
meteor frozen
yeah you could just survive forever like
that in hibernation
so it could just go across the universe
billions of miles you know billions of
years
and uh you know
survive
yeah so they had to keep that
mike says this film is basically a chase
movie yeah i mean it's not a real um
complicated i just i like it because
it's pretty straightforward it's pretty
simple it has that 80s
spielbergian small town
kind of thing like everyone's a
character
um you know everyone's likeable you
don't really want to see anybody get
killed necessarily except for that dude
in the movie theater [ __ ] him
it was who kept like talking
but but he does get killed so that's
happy but everybody else you don't
really want to see him get killed so
everyone's just kind of likable people
and they're basically just trying to
like get the hell away from
whatever the hell this is and they're
trying to like figure out what it is
there's like the chase through the sewer
uh [ __ ] kevin dillon rides that
motorcycle through the big sewer like he
goes up on the wall like over the blob
and [ __ ] like that it's just i had
really just forgotten
how
good this movie is it's just very very
entertaining it doesn't have any slow
spots
uh special effects look great it's super
gory it's it's just it has a good score
it's just it's super
um
it's super it's not bleak necessarily
because it has like a more or less happy
end well kind of it has more or less a
happy ending but
a lot of people get killed like and
people you don't think or you don't want
to get killed absolutely do get killed
and then like i said it's a little more
cynical than the 50s one because you
find out that it's actually this top
secret government
uh project and they're basically
once the meteor lands and the blob gets
out the scientists or at least the main
guy
he's kind of more the bad guy like all
the other government people are like
okay because once that guy gets killed
they're like [ __ ] that guy like they
just frag him because they didn't really
want to go along with it because i think
that
he was the one that came up with it and
then when it crash landed in this town i
think he was basically one of those
let's just see what happens type of
situation and they're like uh these are
all people that are gonna get eaten by
the blob that's probably not good and
he's just like no no it's gonna be fine
so there was like definitely like a
government conspiracy type uh you know
angle to it as well which wasn't in the
50s one um but it's still but that said
it still maintains that kind of like you
said a little bit of uh optimism or
i don't know it's just like a very
likable very enjoyable movie despite how
dark it is and despite how gory it is
now i will say like the end scene with
the crazy
preacher
who
he saved some of it he saved some of it
like from the freezer and then like be
like builds his own cult around it
essentially
and it almost seems the last scene it
almost kind of seems like they're
setting up a sequel
although frank darabot said no that
wasn't his intention
like he's like he's like no i just
wanted to have this little thing at the
end but
it definitely does seem like they're
setting up a sequel although i don't
think they ever i mean they never made
one
but they've done well
no well this movie didn't do well which
listen to this this this sucks
so this movie as awesome as this movie
is because i love this movie and i and
watching it again last night just
cemented my love for it because i hadn't
seen it for a really long time
this movie cost anywhere between okay so
wikipedia says 10 million
imdb says 19 million i'm not sure which
one of those are correct yeah that's
that's a very large difference i'm not
really sure which one of those is
correct but
uh it doesn't really matter because it
only made eight million damn at the box
office that's a flop now yeah big time
and it could have been i mean there
probably were a lot of reasons um the
frank darabon and like some of the
director and stuff said well
they didn't think that it was uh
promoted very well another thing too was
that this movie came out at right around
the same time i mean this is opening
weekend it opened eighth
but
this opened right around the same time i
think as
die hard
um
who framed roger rabbit
big i mean it's like all cocktail that
tom cruise movie there's like so all the
beaches i think came out around the same
time so there were all these like
massive what are now classic movies all
came out like right around the same time
as this so this just got creamed
um
and it's really sad because
i mean it's so it's such an excellent
movie and particularly one that's like a
remake
you know like we were saying like you
know the 80s was really the heyday of
50s remakes that were way way better
than the originals
and this is way way better than the
airport it's good flip it holds up it
definitely does it definitely does i
mean i still love the special effects
look [ __ ] great like all the gore
yeah yeah i mean just [ __ ] fantastic
it has a good american spielbergian
[ __ ] scope to it it just it's just a
good movie yeah
yeah
uh danny rolling ago so he says the
original has that cool catchy song i
will give it that i do like i do like
the original blob song but i think that
that's maybe
why people see it as like so cheesy
is because that song is just like you
know it's the little blob song you know
what i mean it's like oh a cute space
alien yeah jujube coming from space you
know what i mean whereas this one is
just very much like no it's going to eat
the whole entire town yeah sci-fi and
eat off your face sci-fi of the 50s you
know what i mean was bottom of the
barrel they were they marketed to kids
yeah you know uh it's a
not a good move you know
very few there were very few sci-fi
movies of the 50s that were
respectable
war of the worlds uh forbidden planet
uh day the earth stood still
that's probably about it there might be
another one there
most of them most of them kind of sucked
well they were just kind of cheap pretty
good
and i mean i was i was watching
something earlier that said you know 50s
monster movies like a lot of times it
would be like five percent like cool
scenes of the monster attacking somebody
like the giant tarantula or whatever and
then the rest of it would just be like
dudes in suits or lab coats standing
around yaking about talking on the phone
talking on the phone from their audit
from their offices i think it was red
letter media because i was watching a
thing earlier because they did a like a
45 minute uh talk about the blob and
they were saying yeah the 50s movies
they said well maybe they did that on
purpose because they knew that like in
the 50s everybody would be making out
the whole time yeah it could have been
like through the whole movie and then
just like oh here's like the two minutes
of cool monster action and then they
just go back to making out remember
creature from the black lagoon was
pretty good those 50s yeah yeah yeah
yeah well no creature from the black
lagoon was earlier earlier but they did
a second one revenge of the creature
in
early 50s i think which is actually not
bad yeah it's actually not bad i
remember it's not as good as the
original but it's still pretty good i
remember the original being pretty good
but it's not 50s
yeah i'm pretty sure the creature from
the bracket i think it was 40 oh
might have been late 30s
[ __ ] now i can't that old i don't think
it was that old i can now i can't even
remember it might have been 40s maybe i
don't know i can't remember now
i could be totally wrong
um yeah cheryl said wow big flop yeah
unfortunately um but like i said i don't
it doesn't have anything to do with the
quality of the movie i just think it was
because one there were so many other
big movies that came out right around
the same time
but i don't know i don't know if it
wasn't marketed correctly or if it's
just nobody was in the mood for it or
i don't really know and that's like a
really a shame because this is like a
really really good horror flick uh
slasher
slasher fred
one of my favorite 80s movies is the
classic horror child's play yeah i
really like that one too we saw did we
see like the remake just recently that
was all right i mean yeah the remake
wasn't that good it's yeah i mean it was
okay but
it was unnecessary yeah i kind of feel
like that's why and that's why i kind of
like this run of 80s
remakes of 50s movies that actually like
modernized and improved upon them
because they were good ideas that were
you know not really that well done back
then if you're gonna do a remake don't
take something that was like awesome the
first time like halloween or texas
chainsaw massacre and remake that why
remake that remake something that kind
of sucked the first time yeah but was a
good idea
i don't have a problem with it then
don't remake something good why bother
there's a couple exceptions the remake
of night of the living dead was pretty
good but it was just another zombie
movie it wasn't this same movie yeah you
know i actually like the original better
but i do as well but the 1991 you're
talking about the 1990s like the tom
cevini directed one it was pretty good
too but i could say yeah it's pretty
good i consider it to be a different
zombie movie though
yeah i mean it's similar but yeah it's
not entirely the same really the same
yeah
but you know i it's so i've said that
for a long time it's just i you know
i've seen like zillions of movies that
were made from the 50s to the 70s that
were really cool ideas but
you know the people didn't have
the you know didn't have enough budget
or they didn't really know what they
were doing or it was kind of like
technically you know not all that good
and it's like but it was a good story or
there was something like good about it
and somebody could totally
remake that if you wanted to do a remake
[ __ ] i've been saying this a long time
because remember we talked about uh
manos the hands of fate
um which is an awful movie although it's
like pretty entertaining in its
awfulness
but i still maintain
that that's a good idea yeah i mean if
somebody did that right that would be
really creepy i think i think it's a
creepy idea they just didn't
he didn't have the the money or the
technical know-how
to pull that off but it was a good idea
so you know if somebody wanted to remake
it i don't know why nobody has
nowadays maybe the original is good
enough for everybody uh camp guy says i
got blob stuff in my freezer and
refrigerator
uh shimarlo scott says ghostface is my
favorite slasher so i'm guessing the
scream ones
and what else
he was also talking about them doing a
hellraiser remake he says it's going to
be good i doubt it i didn't like the
first ones
i liked the first tell razer the second
one was all right uh the other ones
after that like you know diminishing
returns yeah
you know but um i didn't even really
like the first one
uh if you guys ever seen the original
fright night i love the original friday
night actually uh we we talked about it
a while back that's actually one of my
favorite movies from the 80s easily one
of my favorite horror comedies
um just really really that's a really
really fun movie
they remade that too but that also was
the remake wasn't that good hellraiser
was cool back in the day but only in the
scenes that had the damn cenobites in it
the rest of the [ __ ] was just kind of
like a 50s movie a lot of talking
and uh you know some people like them
they're kind of like weird romances i
guess they were kind of weird for the
days but i saw them recently we watched
them and i was like these are kind of
boring
but it's just because you know your
threshold has changed a lot since then
well when clive barker first came out
you didn't really have a lot of
mainstreamed
stuff that that was that that was that
extreme right you didn't have like a lot
of this weird like s m yes bdsm over the
top you know now it's everyone's just
like yawn but back in the 80s when he
wrote it
i mean that was like nobody was doing
that it was like really subversive so
what was better a better series than
just better movies overall was the whole
uh phantasm series that just got better
as it went they were all good and
they were just that was just better
series than than hellraiser by far
fourth row down says uh i'd like to see
a remake of q the winged serpent now see
something like that i do like the
original cue the winged serpent
but as a trip i mean you could make
something really good out of that see
there's like tons there's tons
of movies
there are even like forgotten ones that
you could remake that you could really
do something good with because there's
like a lot of really good ideas in there
most of the time it's just you know the
acting was bad or they didn't have the
money or whatever you know it wasn't
necessarily because the story was a
stupid idea i was talking last night
somebody needs to do is go back and get
all the [ __ ]
everything from superman 4 and [ __ ]
fix that movie and re-edit it
there's enough shot from superman 4
where you could fix
that superman 4 was going to be good man
but they [ __ ] it up they cut
they cut 45 minutes of it out [ __ ]
cannon cannon studios was [ __ ]
falling apart in the middle of the
production people were stealing money
and running you know they were lucky to
get that movie in the can
somebody superman 4 could could be fixed
with with modern technology somebody
asked us to do a show about canon and
other kind of like indie movie studios
which actually might be sort of
interesting like to get to get into
jeffy art says does anyone remember the
movie the stuff i absolutely do actually
i watched that one not too long ago yeah
that's kind of like more
it's a horror movie but it's more like a
satire it's like a satire of consumerism
yeah um
you know i love the scene where [ __ ]
where this stuff like comes out his
mouth and his [ __ ] mouth is all this
big and [ __ ] like that it looks i mean
it looks
fake but i don't know there's something
like really iconic i like about it
somebody asked about attack of the
killer tomatoes also
we'll get around to that one eventually
although i think uh brand's terrible it
is terrible brandon tennold just did it
yeah uh that was the latest one that he
put up was attack of the killer tomatoes
somebody said they liked the friday the
13th reboot i didn't love it you know
what though i didn't mind the texas
chainsaw massacre remake from 2004. that
was okay
that was better than i was expecting
with friday the 13th only the first
three were any good that's true f4 might
i think no that was three was the last
one that i liked maybe no there wasn't
even four um was it five or six that was
good one of those what the one with one
the one with the little cory in it
oh yeah yeah was that five or six
that one was good yeah i get them what
was it a new beginning maybe that was
five
i can't remember i get them all confused
i think i've seen all of them over the
years i remember
i remember the first three are the ones
that stand out for me
and then after that for some reason it
started to fall apart
the second one was the best one
yeah yeah i'm not gonna disagree with
you on that one but like i said i think
it was the fifth one was actually really
decent too but there were a couple like
turds in there also yeah i mean like i
said i've watched them all because
what it's not my favorite horror
franchise though i like slashers but
it's not my favorite sub genre i'm more
like a haunted house
type remaking pumpkin head
no
the original is good enough
you also have to one of the things you
gotta remember about pumpkin head is go
back and try to tell me where pumpkin
head is taking place
because you'll never figure that out
i don't know where that is what you what
year is that the cars are from the 80s
but who the hell is living in a shack in
the 80s
up in the [ __ ] woods of california
there weren't any hillbillies in the 80s
not living like it was night 1920 in
1930
just you know it's a it's a fictional
world that it's taking place in well i
always just thought of it and we talked
we we reviewed it we talked about this
exact thing i said to me it just struck
me as like a fairy fairy tale which so
like i really wasn't worried about where
it was taking place if you're so because
it's kind of a fairy tale rebooting it
wouldn't really matter because it's kind
of taking place out outside of space and
time anyway if you were going to i mean
i don't advocate necessarily
remaking pumpkinhead because i think it
was good the first time but if you were
going to remake it
i would advocate going in a more folk
horror direction like play up the
folklore play up the fairy tale
aspect of it not to the extent of not
like crazy
but
i think you could do something with that
you'd have to put it in the past too
yeah
yeah cheryl says leave pumpkin head
alone yeah honestly i really would not
um yeah kyle's talking about the remake
of rabid i still want to see that
um
i've heard mixed reviews about it but
i'm actually really curious i'll get
around to watching it one of these days
um let's see do do do
night of the comment remake the sentinel
you know what that might be a good one
to do because i really like the original
sentinel
we did a review of that uh quite a while
back
um
but it had a lot of problems too but
it's a good idea
again so i think that maybe i'm
surprised somebody's remade that one i
feel like that one's kind of like a
popular surprise i tried to remake the
keep
yeah see there's a lot of kind of like
lesser known ones like that
that are cool ideas yeah that you could
do and i just so i don't know why i mean
i know why they they keep doing the the
big budget because everybody knows them
yeah they want everybody to come say
everybody's heard of
nightmare on elm street everybody's
heard of texas chainsaw massacre not you
know only horror nerds have heard about
the keep or the sentinel or whatever and
why we make it
yeah it has to happen in world war ii
and then the fans of the keep
it'd be hard for that movie to make new
fans yeah it's the wrong generation so
it's best just to talk about the old
movie and go back and look at it again
i'd like to remake the island
that's a [ __ ] great movie we're
[ __ ] kane michael kane
about the damn inbred pirates out on the
[ __ ] island off the coast of florida
here that was a [ __ ] great movie a
lot of it
it was from a book they cut a lot of it
out
um you could remake that that'd be cool
as [ __ ] but the problem is is that what
made the album so great was michael
caine
you know
michael caine made that movie great
you'd have to get something to really
carry that you could remake the hand
with michael caine
but yeah oliver stone how are you going
to [ __ ] follow up oliver stone
you know that's what i mean i kind of
feel like and that but again that movie
is good the way it is just the way it is
i don't think it needs to be modernized
or remade or anything
i'm talking more i'm talking more about
movies that and and it doesn't even
necessarily have to be something that
like everybody knows it's just that well
i want to make a movie and i can't think
of an original idea so i want to remake
something but just like you know there's
there's a lot of fertile ground out
there that you can like pick from if you
must remake something look at mandy
that's all original movie that
motherfucker's badass
yeah i mean and then uh uh you know
nicholas cage will work out so he'll
he'll [ __ ] do some crazy ass [ __ ]
some of it [ __ ] gr great some of it
[ __ ] terrible but you know he's gonna
cage the [ __ ] out in every [ __ ] movie
he doesn't phone it in he's gonna he's
you're gonna get your money's worth the
[ __ ] nick cage is in it he's gonna
cage he's gonna cage will cage he's a
cajun [ __ ]
he's gonna do it what was the one where
he's uh
you know chuck e cheese's didn't say a
word to the whole movie willie's
wonderland willie's wonderland great
movie
yeah i had a great night i had a good
time with that one colorado space was
pretty good some people didn't think it
worked i thought it did
it had a couple little things i didn't
like about it but overall i thought it
was a really good adaptation yeah kyle
says a remake of god told me to has
potential now see
that's another one because i really did
like that movie
but the concept of it is so cool that i
think that that could totally be
modernized and that might work out jeffy
art asks has anyone seen lamora a
child's tale of the supernatural i have
but it was a very long time ago and i've
actually really been wanting to revisit
that because it keeps like coming up
when i'm looking around for other things
and i'm like oh yeah i should rewatch
that slasher fred says i sure would love
to do a remake of jaws
which i guess he's being sarcastic but
you know
um yeah danny rowling says it's a
valentine's day slasher from 2001 called
valentine actually i think they just
added that on
hulu
i want to say
because i was thinking about maybe we
could do a matinee on it because i
remember that being okay
you know i remember being okay
um
all right so are are we done talking
about the blob
okay so i mean we mostly talked about
the blob but yeah so if you haven't seen
it where did we see it we saw it on
amazon prime right yeah um yeah so you
can you can rent it for 2.99 3.99
however much it was but yeah i mean if
you like really gory 80s horror this is
like a really really good one and i feel
like a lot of people don't really talk
about it even when they talk about good
80s remake of 50 stuff like like i said
like the fly or the thing this
absolutely is up there
with those uh so yeah check it out and
uh we're gonna be back tomorrow night
for our regular show
which is going to be about
fast food restaurant massacres
so it's going to be a little bit of a
bummer but you know that's what won the
polls so that's what we're going to do
uh so yeah uh thanks everybody for
dropping by this afternoon and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow evening
bye